[Music]
for the cover piece this week cindu
looks at how the Chinese Communist Party
spotted the business opportunity in the
green industry long ago China now covers
more than three4 of the world's solar
panels while a third of electric
vehicles sold in Britain are made in
China this is the start of China's green
era cindu joins me now to discuss along
with Tony Daner former head of the
CBI um Cindy you right in this week's uh
magazine about China's green plans and
how it ties in with their economic
Ambitions tell us more about this yeah
so um China has basically spotted an
economic opportunity here in the global
dry for Renewables um the developed W
has been getting more and more climate
guilt over the last you know 10 15 20
years um and China you know it is the
world's largest polluter but it's also
the factory of the world as well so what
happened was as soon as um as early as
20 2005 really China's been looking into
Renewables as an export opportunity it's
really wanting to move on from the three
things that unpend its economy before
which is clothing home electronics and
furniture and going into much more
high-tech Green Tech stuff and this is
great you know this is a great business
opportunity because the world is only
demanding more of these things not less
um and what's amazing is you know as
ever is the case with China when they
set their mind to doing something the
industry just moves so incredibly fast
uh that we're now looking at basically
real domination of various Renewables
industries from Eves to lithium
batteries to solar power to wind power
all of these things at the same time the
West is not supporting its own
businesses in competing with China on
these as much as the Chinese government
is so you see this kind of imbalance
going on T has the West been left behind
on this and specifically how is Britain
fairing at a time when for instance you
know the American government to have the
inflation reduction act for instance is
there a danger that Britain is
particularly left behind in the race for
Renewables yes absolutely and uh Cindy
described it absolutely correctly you
know by by my numbers I think Chinese
green stimulus is double the inflation
reduction act in the US is four times
the EU stimulus and I know that in
British politics we're criticizing the
labor party for wanting to spend 28
billion pounds on green stimulus that
would be a 40th of China so we are left
as a country uh really once quite ahead
on a lot of areas of Green Technology of
green industry suddenly finding
ourselves completely gunned by the rest
of the world and do you think perhaps
there's a chance then that the Net Zero
agenda can become an issue of National
Security and all this and actually that
we we've seen some powers in terms of uh
the National Security Act and Industry
act you think that should be extended in
terms of these PHS and government should
play much more of a role in order to try
and catch up with what the Chinese are
ahead and lot of us on oh I worry about
that I worry about that I want to go
straight to the wedge issue for
spectator audience right which is a a
skepticism a hawkishness towards China
but at the end of the day this is about
markets right and in a way EVS are just
the latest of yet another manufactured
good at which China can dominate the
world for all kinds of reasons and as
you say you know the argument against
the Chinese uh sort of dominating the EV
Market is either one of well their
subsidies are too high but to be honest
this is a sector that everybody's
subsidizing even us in the UK are
subsidizing this Market or we're going
to claim it's a national security issue
and I think we just need to be careful
about that one right you will know more
than me about the China issue and how
the UK needs to confront China in the
new world I think it's a stretch to say
that them owning revs is a big national
security threat there are clearly some
strategic Industries we need to be
careful about I just don't think the
cars on our street are one of them uh
Cindy um Tony there talks about you know
markets and I wondered how much is this
about kind of you know Beijing top down
order State Control since 2005 or has
this just been something that's organic
and responding to kind of changes you
know in the west rather than any kind of
central dictat you know what it was it
was China in a way that it does throwing
a lot of money at things and just seeing
what sticks right so in 2015 it has this
industrial policy called uh made in
China 2025 which is basically giving
itself a 10-year window in which to
really excel at the high-tech industries
of the future semiconductors robotics
Aerospace Renewables as well and it's
just chucked lots of money at all of
these sectors and Renewables has been
the biggest success story from this not
so much semiconductors and not so much
robotic
all of these other things um and so that
this is we're looking back now and
thinking oh my God how do they do that
actually they they bet on a lot of
horses um and when it comes to you know
the Net Zero agenda you know I think
there will be an interpretation of the
story which is that oh China's been
egging us on to go to Net Zero just so
that we would buy their goods it's not
so much that it's that it's been clear
for quite a long time that this is what
the world where the world needed to go
in tackling climate change it's been
clear it's been clear to the West as
well I mean we've been driving this kind
of climate targets what we haven't been
doing is driving the industry that would
be providing these Goods so the UK is
this world's second largest installer of
offshore wind but we don't have a wind
manufacturing industry in this country
to speak of so why don't we so it's that
kind of in congruity that China doesn't
really have because it's just you know
thinking about all of these things as
business opportunities very
strategically and then to Tony's point
about the security concerns I mean I
think let's see how much just in 10 15
years they really dominate the eveve
market right I mean it is technically
possible for an electric vehicle to be
Switched Off by manufacturer remotely
right so let's say 2third of British
cars on EES on the roads are Chinese in
20 years if they all on mass shut down
clearly that's a security risk but there
are so many other ifs involved in that
could the Chinese company will it will
it really do that considering that would
be pretty much suicide for that company
to be kind of killing its customers uh
will the Chinese Communist Party really
demand that of a company um all of these
different things I think there are a lot
of ifs here but when we talk about
National Security in this kind of
fevered era that we're in at the moment
it's a lot of about as but what is the
potential for something to go wrong what
is the potential for something to happen
and you know it's technically possible
but will it really happen and that's the
that's the analysis that you know policy
makers have to make
tny well look I think what this whole
thing poses a real question about is can
the UK compete in a green Industrial
Revolution that is mostly made
affordable by big countries in the world
through subsidy and we have a government
right now that doesn't want to
participate in subsidy although by the
way we'll throw in a little bit for
Nissan the other week and a little bit
for you know BMW uh and mini uh a few
months ago so I think the government's a
little bit confused about what their St
really is but this is a government that
doesn't want to compete with the
inflation reduction act in the US or
with the Chinese or the European
stimulus and I understand why I
understand the principles behind why but
let's be clear it means you lose right
and then we have a labor party who want
to invest at uh you know what we regard
as a pretty big amount but even that
isn't going to be sufficient and so I
think Britain needs a more thoughtful
and a smarter Net Zero strategy than
we've had so far you know we've gone
from Boris Johnson's 10-point plan which
I kind of loved actually Boris doesn't
get enough credit for being an absolute
green believer but it was a you know it
was an unprioritized strategy we're
going to have more of everything every
form of you know low carbon energy we're
going to have all these kind of product
markets like Eevee to a rishy sunak
strategy which seems to be Retreat and
of course the truth has to be somewhere
in between Britain is going to have to
work out what are our bets in the green
economy we don't have a lot of stimulus
right we don't have a lot of uh we do
actually have quite a few advantages and
things as you said like wind and we do
have suon EVS so let's have a strategy
that places some bets rather than being
subscale in everything in a world where
scale matters yeah absolutely and um for
my piece I spoke to um Adam Burman who
is at energy UK one of the industry
groups um involved in talking to these
energy companies in the UK and his idea
was basically talking about these nent
industries like hydrogen carbon capture
and storage with stuff that China hasn't
really and nobody in the world has
really kind of cracked because the
technology hasn't really existed just
yet so why don't we use the British R&D
specialities here and we should be that
would be a cheaper and more Focus way of
doing these things rather than the
American or the Chinese way which has a
lot of wastage involved when it comes to
the money involved so I think we could
still respect back the lead it's just
that Richie sunak is not talking about
it all he's talking about is watering
Down The Net Zero Target or turning
pushing back the petrol car ban without
really talking about what he can be
doing for the EV companies in this
country so there there is still
inconsistency from the British approach
but maybe K will change that shortly
well I think whoever is in power right
we are subscale in what is a continental
sized economics right that's what green
markets have become Continental sized so
I think on all of these choices which
forms of energy offshore wind onshore
wind solar hydrogen which color hydrogen
I think Britain needs to take a very
simple Choice are we going to be
distinctive in this are we going to
genuinely lead the world are we going to
be competitive in this in other words we
need to kind of keep up but we're not
going to kid ourselves we'll be World
beating or do you know what is it okay
to buy them in is it okay to import them
is it okay that China makes our electric
vehicles is it okay that China makes the
blades in our wind turbines maybe the
answer is yes I don't what the right
answer is but no government's going to
have enough money in the UK to make all
these bets we're going to have to choose
I what have been the thing stopping us
from making those choices I mean
obviously the question of money and
obviously money's type right now it's
the refrain I hear most in Westminster
and White Hall is you know there is no
money left so okay it's not just about
about resources um I don't particularly
think it's going to be a sort of an an
election issue in terms of the kind of
you know Green issues about investment
Etc what is it in terms of policy issues
that been stopping us from coming down
on the right the side whether it be
right or wrong Etc coming down one side
for total what are the kind of things
that you've seen in terms of uh policy
in inhibitions in the last few years and
decade or so look I think it's just an
inability to choose right and maybe I'm
sorry to get a bit existential here
maybe that's about us coming to terms
with the size that we are and our
ability to compete in a world that's
increasingly Continental right maybe
we'll look back at this and saying it's
a Natural Choice that a country like us
needs to make post brexit we're not in a
big scale Market that therefore has
probably got the scale to play at
everything uh we're going to have to
choose our bets we're going to have to
be pluckier Boulder braver and I think
when you look at the UK I mean there are
some areas where we have natural
Advantage you've spoken about some of
them right wind is the obvious one right
Pur Boris used to get mocked for saying
we should be the Saudi Arabia of wind
but of course he was right right wind is
an obvious area where the UK should
dominate there are definitely parts of
the EV value chain where we can Dominate
and lead the world particularly in R&D
the idea that we're going to compete on
assembly cheap assembly of electric
vehicle uh cars right is a hard one but
we probably do have to be competitive in
it we do have to have some kind of
presence and in the end like every
market right uh something being cheap is
one reason to buy it but something being
better quality better brand better
design better style I mean that's the
way the car markets always worked um
James so one of the companies that I
looked at uh that has failed in in
recent months is British Vault a British
startup which looked at um battery
making and it was going to be one of the
two gigafactories of making batteries in
the UK they went busted in January and
the former CEO has since then come out
and blamed you know to your to your
question blamed government instability
you know during the time over the last
over the last year when they were
struggling financially they had three
different Prime Ministers they have
numerous different secretaries of State
dealing with them on in different ways
um he directly pointed the finger of
blame at the treasury as well for not
releasing funding because of the
political instability so I think part of
it is just that we've had so many
leaders you know talk about Boris
Johnson's 10-point plan that was only
two years ago right and now we've got a
leader who's totally watering down Net
Zero so I think that is also a part of
it and maybe after the next election
things will stabilize a bit more but the
British political termoil can't be R out
I think we've focused mostly in this
discussion on Britain um Cindy but how's
it all gone down in China and recently
you wot in the piece about uh president
Z visiting America and trying to signal
to the West that you China is still open
for business um one element to this is
the economics there's also the domestic
Poli seeks to consider and a more
prosperous middle class wanting to
ensure you have higher environmental
standards just talk us through that yeah
exactly so we often obviously see
stories through British lens
understandably but actually for China
this kind of export opportunity is also
about making sure that the country
becomes cleaner domestically as well and
this might sound crazy to people
watching at home because Beijing is so
polluted you know we know all about the
country's opening of new coal plants all
of these things are happening and it's
true but actually because of the growing
middle classes in China they're
demanding not necessarily political
rights so far but the right for their
children to breathe safe air to drink
safe water and the government um in the
last nine years have said that they've
announced the war on pollution basically
and the figures show that um
International observers have shown that
um Beijing air pollution is been halfed
in the last 10 years uh that there are
hundreds of millions more people with
access to Safe Drinking Water because
the rivers have been cleaned up so what
we've seen in China is a huge Industrial
Revolution uh a huge scale of Industrial
Revolution and really fast pace uh over
the reform era but now as people get
richer and as economy slows down they're
demanding more things like just
Environmental Conservation just being
able to have access to Safe air and
water and the government is trying to
give that to them because otherwise it
becomes a legitimacy problem for the CCP
as well you know air pollution was one
of the most controversial issues for
lots of Chinese middle- class people not
so much voting rights but that so so for
the Chinese communist party they had to
do something about it and and that's why
we see their domestic market for
Renewables is also huge you know Chinese
people are buying EES on mass as well so
I think that's fascinating to think
about this kind of coal uh guzzling
country also becoming the green uh the
engine of the Green Revolution globally
you know a lot of people will say uh
this is hypocrisy on the part of the
Chinese to be sort of pushing EVS our
way and dominating markets while
simultaneously investing in Coal I mean
I think every economy in the world is
guilty of such hypocrisy right now right
and it's not really hypocrisy it's
trying to manage this transition one of
the interesting UK political points that
hits this discussion is Rishi sunak
choosing to ban sorry to push back the
ban uh on uh on traditional cars and
sort of postpone that idea of everybody
switching to EVS you know that was done
for electoral purposes but it has had a
knock-on consequence on the economic
viability of the EV market right the
truth was Britain was a highly
competitive destination for electric
vehicle manufacturing assembly R&D
battery production because we had
basically said by 2030 this Market is go
and once you put that back for political
reasons and if if we have an election
where actually we're going to have
parties trying to use green deadlines
green targets as a political football
because they think the voters like it
that will have an economic consequence
right pushing back by 5 years right the
deadline for every switching to EVS
pushes back the development of the
market makes Britain a little less
competitive so there is a risk in an
election year if we want to try and row
back if the conservatives want to row
back from Green pledges in order to win
votes there is an economic KnockOn
effect in a market where we're already
struggling to compete so that's my
little pitch for keeping up green
targets not because I'm trying to be
some green campaigner but because that's
the way one of the ways in which we can
compete economically with people who are
much bigger than us
[Music]